[拍手]
東京堂
ある村から参りましたん
柔らかっ
健康1300
侵入する中13%という
それ占いん
こんな
的な裏です
これでもねー東京なんです
私は東京の花村で人形共有することです
をないだー
古代の
子どもたちがいいですね
楢村に預けに行ってくれて
を積みされたんですよ
は人形という仕事をしています
したりとドーンとしてい
しこりだよ
あー杉江て言ってくれたん
あんでこれカーブか東京の木こりという見方をしてください
pr していこうかなーという
東京の
一人は
そういう気は遣ってるかっ
次の日をやっ
杉と聞いていただいてください
ちょっときいてるッ
本性だよっている方とかさせている方がしますか
よろしいですかありがとうございます
a そのまずたい吹いていただいて
王者の疑いのあるもしくはこうかもしれないという方を上げております
a その中で
水曜金額られればいいのにそう出来ません
すぐになってなければいいようにちょっとでも思ったことがあるから
そのままだけは皆がは犠牲
ありがとうございます
上畑町駅ですね
はいりません
web ショップですはぁ
私はあのそのすぎようですねはい
仕事をしています
てい
私実は調子語るんですけど花粉症だったんですけど
この仕事をやってが追ったああっ
これ
あとこれ
よくわかりません
俺が次のパブがあった
みなさんが知ってるイメージしている新聞なんとちょっと違う
ピュア買った
ああああああ
なんで多分煽ったんだと思う皆さんが吸ってるのはちょっと交え気があるのかどうかと
彼らがはの波
何もあのないですか ui
おそらくこうじゃないのかなうわぁ
そういうスギ雪アンディこの日本中に得られたのかな
不振を持っている方もいると思うんですけど
ツアー多くの炭の家は戦後に植えられています
ご存知の方もいるかもしれないですけど
練習船五っていうのは黒剤が大量に必要だったんですん
本至る所で屋外が伐採されました
て戦争が終わって
復興を破って
病暮らしてる人がひと山を生んだと思う
そこには萩山ができません
そこで何を得ようかと思った時いい
[音楽]
本陣
日本人でしまいですねー
おい過ぎというのがすごくな子が
行ったら大臣されてきまし
クリプトメディア japonica 2炉へず画面があるチックリプトメディア
ジャポニカというのが
次の学名です
これは
いろんな訳し方あるんですけれども日本の隠れたというかなぁと
訳す人もいるぐらいかしくなすぎという気は大事にされています
日本の風土にもよく合っている
北は北海道の一部南は沖縄別馬で全国で終わっ
なのでです木を植えよう
次のがいいいいい
そうで萩山目がないですけど
そういうこといっ
昨日6カシャッキですね中央すごいコニー
are you
束になった重い内容2つも3つもしょっ a
日本へ一歩一歩山を
思っていたんです
口で言うのはすごく簡単ですけどこれ私も行っています
本当に上から火が出る
こともあります
本当にそういう思いをして入るようですね朝早くからやっぱり
ちょいあげる
そしてそこから仕事が始まる
1本1本
大切に
枯れないように山に植えていきます
放題なはぎやがです
その中に1本1本を植えていったん
私の
僕たちのおじいちゃんおばあちゃん世代です
私たちも
このように今でも同じように異人種的ですけど同じように今口で甲や指一本一本植えて
非常にやはり大変です
日は
上田と
下草られていることをん
植えた苗木の場合いいん
したがいっぱい入ってことですね夏になると
先ほど売れた会場母逃げます
た草がには上高い子の周りに記者が入っているそういった熱いな治療後ラオウ
昔
そのお爺さんはたんです
村人総出で朝早くから理由前から山に登っていや上がっては勝つ気になる前には終わら
せたいという思いに朝早く
暗いうちから山に出かけていて
その台の前の着差をどんどんどんどんあります
出雲杜氏はさあ水を三
今みたいにペット包丁でがないんですよ
商品を像が
一生銀含めコインにはいてさんはに降りてみ作ってきて
それを皆で飲みながら
張建銘エンカン方を草を刈ったぞ
私たちは
山あり川じゃなくてくださいあの
ありバラエティを伝えます
昔の家とは
草刈鎌 heaven 彼はですね浜で
放題な山を前にして彼まで調整していた
毎日毎日暑いさなかだっ
を支えます
炭干しに捧げるってあまり疾患ないですよ
着知りたい
六連星さんは刺されるのはお前が悪い
謎
さされる前に発症し付いいじゃないと
表示3款と項女スズメ場所
版って殺したん
すごいなぁと思いますけれどちょっと負けていけないんですけどそれぐらい
まあ夏の暑い最中のした借りは
それを7年間
続けたとにっぽんどは
ランダー団地が育っ
院展の通りこれはもう10年12年位たっ
8年目から4年毎におおよそ4年ごとに
な家という作業しまう
これは世界に回しても日本とニュージーランドの一部でやっていると言われている
ぐらい
ほとんどの国ではやられていません本独自の文化です
antec の枝部長するか3つの
一つは
星の梁材
姫遠くない昔は約8 no なんと言われます
平野とってエルヴィンぐらいの人さになった時に枝を1本1本の動きにあなたで落とし
てい
そうすると
だんだんだん各地は取ってい
枝を落として後がだんだん埋まっていくんです
ハーフ空軍
そうすると
柱を読解だしたら傷が中に隠れているので表に挙げてもらう
そういったことが昔は
重宝されて先入れかにやるものとしていた
ただいま日本の建築はだいぶ様変わりします
そういったものが必要とされなくなります
需要がなくなったん
もう一つの目的は通直官は描きを育てる
金子はあまり行かないかもしれません
いく考えというのはこの日にしか使えません
まずすぐと完全に道部とか
費用なんとだと思い浮かべてもらいたいん
日の道
だんだん細くなりますね
それというのはエナが出ているところから枝に養分を取られる人気を不足なっ
の枝物という作業は
枝を落としてあげることでそこまで同じ人砂泥
太ってくれます
そうするとやはり同じように柱を撮ったりとかした時に
枝落しないとはこういう性肥料が良いのが多いされています
そうすると柱を取ると末広がりでも普段なっちゃう
が枝子としてあげるとまっすぐ座ってまとまりの良い
に育ってくる
裏が少ない使いやすい嘘
それが通直たまん
最後は
ご覧の上に枝を落としてあげるとよりが明るくなります
いたべきの事例
林の中に光が届くことで自分のオールドがどんどん上がってくる
知名度温度が上がると太陽っていうかという
誰かにいる微生物たちが土の中の微生物が活発におけるような
枝葉
動植物の4階そういったものをどんどん分科会として土に変えてい
そういうつの目的があってくる枝物という作業をしているんですが
一本一本このように
に登って4年ごとに4回に分けて行っ
おめでたを通していただき
それをつくって落ち葉がかかります
ポスター多かった
今は機は安いです
代は安いのでなかなかそのを今をかけることができません
な述べその枝打ちという文化も
どんどんされてい
ようやくそうしてきれいな方に廃止になってきたところで
藩閥よく聞きませんです
旱魃の時期を迎えます
約樹齢20年植えてから20年目ぐらいになると反発してあげます
なぜか
まいねえ者はちょっと覚え
出しです
by 電車のチェス火のないところに立っちゃうといい
静めず状態だとなっていうかこう
こんな感じですよ
l となりの人がいろいろデー
そんなに上でも大抵つ折れないですよ
足付方だと思う
日も同じなるんですアーリーが組んでくると風が食い気好結果からなくてもいいですよ
根っこからずになっている
そうすると例えば注意躁状態を続けて休暇ばするとへっこがっていないのに周りが開い
ちゃったらどうなります
買われてしまう
たので
20年目から
定期的に
アンバー超して空間をですね少しずつ見ながら
端末を繰り返していく数回
そうしてそれだけど今まで植えてから
スタッフ下がり押して餌が縁をして
版末を繰り返して
ようやく育ってちわ
使えるようになります
ここは8歳をしてい
スレイ
ちょうど使いの動きです
私たちは今日1本1本丁寧に聞いて
建築材料であったりある材料であったり
おもちゃであっそういったものに使ってもらえるように
今から大事に切り出しています
今
1本の木が早く皆はず見直されてきています
どうしてかというと
いったように
ことを使い頃になってきたから
思い出してください
線を
上てくれた
僕たちの
おじいちゃんおばあちゃんたち世界の人たちが一本一本抜いてくれたわけです
ん
熱い炎天下の中村人装具で山に入って草を買ってくれば
想像して育ててきた機がいまー
使い道ざっ
そのおじいさんガチでおばあさんたちは使えないんです
自分が使うわけじゃないんです
魚たちの子どもや孫のためを
植えて育ててきたことなんです
それが今私たちの代になってようやく使うことを迎えていくがこのにゃん
おかげさまで
お子
は原村口を使っていくような指摘内容だけ
もらえましょうていました
とても気持ちがいいです
アブ小の原因はた頃とかにもストレスとか食事とか色々言われてますけど
もしかしたらこのようなインすればスペースもいわばじゃないでもう
部屋が書くんじゃなくてもっ
もう少し楽になれましたん
僕たちは
このようにまたつかしてもらったの敵を受ける
また僕たちが木を植えて
次の次の世代の
人たちが使うように田植え続けてい
[音楽]
これがこの
飛距離
最初人形といった時理解されてございませんですが
日本の中で数少ない財布 a 3可能な資源があっ
入ってもらえればまた使える
このような資源なかなかない
それがこの日本であれば機航空度でありざー
椅子ので端ても続けることができる
そういった仕事にアーレンで私はすごく
うれしい
最後
もう市
思います
それでも
いただいています
そのご静聴ありがとうございます
はぁ